[Music]  this song anywhere is one of those  records that I definitely felt like I  needed to escape I was in LA I was  making my music and I felt really I  don't know still stuck I'm a city girl  so for me being anywhere like with Beach  and Sun at the time I start kind of like  losing my mind so I kind of wanted to  just get away  [Music]  the response that this song has had is  that people really have been like thank  you I really this moment of freedom of  breaking out from I don't know my  relationship or breaking out from this  or that and I don't know I feel like  it's helped a lot of people I actually  have no idea what I'm saying  I really well how this song happened is  that that post-chorus was just chopped  up my voice is just chopped up so I  actually I'm not saying anything so you  guys can pick it up but we can't say  that I'm saying like take me anywhere  you wanna be EEE maybe we could do that  [Music]